oh what a power move wo between the legs puts
it right on his tap that's a thing of beauty
it's an absolute Mona Lisa here's Garland in
front for bler he beats he scores Garland with
the dish bler with the finish and it's two
nothing nice job Joshua is helping out but
it's Garland here with the hands and the pass
and then de at the front of the net D in to
the left Luger with the Finish to the right that
is a nice move right near the blue paint right
Conor Timmons nice pass in the middle David C
through C scores and he just comes flying off
the benches he got a fresh body a quick little
turn up and how about this pass H the tap splits
the middle and H shows three patience and hand
backand to the forehand lifts it up and over the
glove jackets come up for the puck oh nice move
there and then fantelli after beating Miley goes
between the legs and the the jackets fantelli
scores fantelli starts and finishes the play
what a great individual effort by the rookie
fantelli whoa between the legs and then Kent
Johnson how about the skill on this line Kent
Johnson bats it out of the air gets it on his
stick and it's a double clutch and panelli says
get me that Puck and there whips it yeah that's
got to feel good here's the redot Zack Hyman
BS in his last nine and make it 10 what a goal
by Zack kyman little button hook spin by himman
he looks up and says I'm taking this one to the
post and that's exactly what he did jams it Far
Side protecting the plck hole my goodness from
the back end to the forehead that's a brilliant
play there by Hyman behind the up for melli to
Moser now machell to the Middle melli With
A Chance and a go at home and it's Michael
carcone unbelievable Matias melli how you
doing and look at this movement melli just
says follow me boys he throws it at the cage and
he finds Michael carcone and watch this play by
carcone off the skate to the stick and into the
back of the [Music] net oh what a play that is
Dave steel down the middle ditch hman hatrack
some kind of look by the captain and Hyman got
a hatrick of hat tricks for his career what a
pass at the end of this great individual effort
little pickpocket spin undresses a hurricane
and then finds him and knows where he is which
is the incredible part for Conor McDavid
as the hats come funneling down onto the
ice here's Bard off the stretch quick shot he
scores that Sinister release in the upper right
hand corner and Bard's got just a little bit
of room the key to this shot is he drags it
in tight to his feet and what that does he pull
it around the defenseman at home s and then the
puck explodes straight up under the ball a beauty
from [Music] Bart to Byfield down to the circle to
the net a chance he scores oh what a power move
by Quinton Byfield look at the hands moving the
feet moving the puck protection everything's going
all at once and it's working together and by the
time the defender tries to cut him off at the pass
there's too much speed and too much strength look
at that Low Shoulder bang he just Falls right
off he bounces right off Clinton Byfield tyru
the middle wide open he scores oh what a play
unbelievable goal by cyou good passing sets this
up right here Jordan Kyrie the old shake and bake
to the middle of the ice and how you going it's
in the back of the net and then the presence of
mine right at the very end to just tuck it five
ho celebrating and he should what a [Music] goal
n Hopkins speaking about L pass McDavid Cuts in
Waits Waits tucks it home cter McDavid a virtuoso
game time goal watch this pent stick handle stick
handle get flurry to bite you know Mark Andre
flurry's an aggressive Bender wants to come out
and challenge that's exactly what he does with
the patience the skill of Conor McDavid to walk
this around tuck it home on the backhand side
absolutely ridiculous goal it'll work it down a
little further Carlson near the front of the net
and Maro scores Jonathan maruso Buri it in tight
how about this pass by William Carlson between the
legs no look NOS Marsha so there and he makes no
mistake going upstairs past Bennington what a pass
and what a finish for v he's fresh and he picks up
the puck look into the net and a save M got his
own rebound score that was not an easy goal to
score much B is he's going to come off the bench
a little chip play and there he goes right down
the middle of the ice has no angle he's below the
dock watch shoot that from I mean that's about a
foot off the uh maybe a foot from the goal line
that's really impressive but you're right like
there's no angle there at all now the right wing
it's mckin TR to get around D with the hip check
mckinn staying with it in front SC go did it hit
the crossb did that not go in the net we're about
to find out and they would have stopped the game
Let's Take a Look folks Nathan McKinnon Blows By
the outside loses the puck gets it over to KI
R and here's the Moment of Truth yeah that's in
baby score that is back top sh it's so guarantee
it for you folks 20 plus minutes he's been a beast
for the pens this year walking in front Smith
backhander he's scars that is what they needed
the big man Gino out in the open Ice can use his
body to Shield off you're thinking please tell
me he sees Riley Smith right here he certainly
does puts it right on his tape beautiful feed
beautiful finish and the jackets counter in the
zone nice move thrown in front turning and hoer
looks by behind them and it's into the net he
you love when that skill and speed executes for
a goal starts down their own end and you can see
OV speed he's going to take the outside because
he's created but then moves inside and now ver
alov he protects the puck and gets it back to
the middle of the ice and as he does marchenko
does what marenko does well great release into
the middle of the net he'll tab it back to Brandon
Hegel now Hegel will wind it up Hegel up the right
side trying to skate away from Everly Brandon
Hegel across they go n COV Brandon Hegel does
a heck of a job here he uses his speed and every
ounce of energy that he has left he just wielded
the puck out of the zone that man three steps of
eyes all looking at Brandon Hegel and COV will be
able to come late on the play look at that talk
about thread the needle no mistake on that one
wall again pop kept in it's bson flipping it stula
and he scores that's a thing of beauty good job in
the four check it's kept in at the line now here
you I think he's going to move it he doesn't but
he flips it to an area where only stsa can get it
stutz's got a step on everybody so no one can see
that pass coming and it arrives flat on the tape
and sta does the rest the KF takes the pck off
the in boards in behind for Alias pson R he scores
the puck went to the point the shot misses the net
M's going to put it up high Pon with the strength
behind the net shielding in quick hands wrap it
around on AO on R and put the Canucks ahead to the
tape of b m down the left wing this time we get it
Thad score he's really put this team on his back
right now comes across so much speed Carter har
just buried back into his neet can't handle that
we underestimate how fast 29 comes in slides out
right under the seven hole on the pad tucks it in
the back hits the line gives to Baldi Baldi drives
in scores well what you saw there with Matt bie
was him finishing the play on the offensive side
what happened 10 seconds before that was how good
back check through the neutral zone right here
look at him back checking all the way and makes
a nice little play gets on his horse rewarded for
great defensive play McMichael for Washington into
space for mantha his backand score what a pass
that's highlight reel the ALU placement pass by
McMichael is a thing of beauty he senses that Mana
can beat them up the ice and all of a sudden Mata
on the play Dees the goal tender onto the backand
k forar theard Works around protus theard across
Murphy scores guard ends up giving a little shake
and bake up here up top and now he's going to his
back and waits for as long as he can for Murphy to
jump in from the weak side of the ice SE at heal
the toes saucer pass right there and it lays nice
and flat right at the same time that Murphy comes
down stick on the ice pokes it up high over the
blocker it'll come back to the Blue Line Josh Mory
shoots and TI the score and it's Gabriel valar's
first goal is a jet how is that for a tip wow the
tip is impressive and so is the battle one out of
the corner jets are able to dig it out go D to D
morsy with eyes up and the tip that is ridiculous
hand ey coordination a tip to Perfection comes
around to weager with a shot stopped rebound and
score chipped in by Zer batted that out of the air
I think this kid's special already he's a smart
smart player and he's got some nice touch Around
the Net and you'll show it to you his shot will
come and then watch Siri here he'll just knock
it right out of the air to give the Flames the
lead back just like that one timer got to spare
and The Twig snaps in half and that allows gandel
a breakaway shorthanded moves into the back
[Applause] hand down comes scandel forehand
backand the scandy man can unreal play with that
Long Reach he's used it to disrupt plays and make
good defensive plays this time it's an absolute
Mona Lisa's got the extra skater Matthews coming
on a power play coming for the leas away
comes Matthews drops it back to neander
neander winds in still has a kneer back
across Matthews two scores Austin Matthews
L elander who dances right through the SC
all by himself and then Matthews who hasn't
had a lot of success against a shuriken
gets one by him but smart well aware play
by the fourth line to get out of the
way let the first liners let's go to
[Music] work